bonjour c'est qu'elle dira merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france retour dans l'exécutif de
sadio camara à la défense il avait été
limogé subban d'eau c'est l'un des
instigateurs du premier coup d'état en
août dernier contre ipk mais aussi
ismaël wagué autre meneur du putsch de
l'été dernier qui conserve son poste à
la réconciliation nationale
tous ces postes stratégiques pour des
militaires quels messages ça envoie
alors merci beaucoup
aujourd'hui avec la mise en place de ce
gouvernement de transition
ce que nous constatons c'est que en plus
du retour quand même de camara à la
défense qui était quand même à la base
même du deuxième coup des temps en f1
nous nous rendons compte que il est
monté dans la hiérarchie
aujourd'hui il est le numéro deux du
gouvernement donc à titre protocolaire
celle qui vient juste après le premier
ministre et au delà de cela
l'agent a encore renforcé son emprise
sur la transition en nommant un nouveau
lite le colonel au poste de l'intérieur
est en conscient donc la sécurité
intérieure salles de classe et quelques
détails à au colonel qui occupait ce
poste
donc le message que nous pouvons
comprendre de cette de la mise en place
de ce gouvernement c'est que la junte a
renforcé son emprise sur la transition
et alors que c'est ce qui constituait un
point de blocage dans le premier
gouvernement
et justement comment va réagir la
communauté internationale notamment la
france
est ce que c'est la fin de la stabilité
politique a d'un coup alors on ne peut
pas dire que c'est la fin de
l'instabilité politique d'autant plus
que les raisons qui ont poussé quand
même à l'élection que deal ainsi pendant
les neuf mois du gouvernement précédent
sont toujours existantes c il s'agit
aujourd'hui de desserrer l'étau des
militaires sur la scène politique et de
s'orienter vers une lutte efficace
contre le terrorisme alors que ce que
nous constatons aujourd'hui c'est que la
junte de plus en plus renforce sa
position et en même temps fragilise donc
la classe politique la communauté
internationale elle devant un fait
accompli
c'est ce qui a agacé je pense à emmanuel
m'apprendre président français surtout
par rapport à la position de la cedeao
ce qu'il faut noter c'est que la cbao ne
pouvait agir autrement que envoyant un
président qui a été quand même a reconnu
par la cour constitutionnelle de son
pays donc venir discuter la cedeao
malgré tout cela ne pouvait uniquement
se limiter qu'à prendre des sanctions
ces briques et c'est ce qui a eu lieu
vous parlez de l'été manuel macron sait
il a donc annoncé avant-hier la fin de
l'opération barkan mais cette dernière
permet de neutraliser quatre terroristes
d'aqmi un preuve que barkan fonctionne
au final est ce pas un peu
contradictoire alors ce qu'il faut noter
c'est que le président français est un
élément qu'on se trouve quand même dans
une position assez délicate d'autant
plus qu' il est actuellement en pré
campagne et au sein de son opinion la
présence de barkan au sahel
de plus en plus décrié il ya un dernier
sondage qui a donné 51% de france est
défavorable à la présence dans le sahel
les résultats se font attendre et on se
rappelle bien qu'au début de
l'intervention française au mali on
avait parlé d'une opération de six mois
et nous sommes presque à neuf mois on ne
peut pas dire que le résultat est
positif parce que en 2002 avant
l'intervention les dialyses ce n'était
que dans le nord du pays aujourd'hui ils
sont et dans le nord et dans le centre
mais en plus de cela ils ont occupé une
partie du burkina et du niger on ne peut
pas parler non
plus d'avoir cuir ou même affaibli les
groupes terroristes parce que même si à
l'heure actuelle il est très difficile
de faire un bilan de l'opération barkan
ce point là on a plus ou moins on peut
noter entre 1100 et 1200 diariste tués
par l'armée française de 2012 a
aujourd'hui et malgré cela les blocs
terroristes se sont de plus en plus
renforcée et donc mac on est devant une
situation sans issue
donc il a tout tenté il a tenté de créer
une force européenne
une task force qu'il appelait takouba
les européens n'ont pas répondu à
l'appel
il a essayé d'organiser les forces
africaines au sein du gsm celle les
etats unis ont refusé de financer donc
aujourd'hui il se trouve devant un
dilemme et en plus de cela je pense que
il a compris que la crise dans le sel ne
peut être résolu uniquement que par les
armes et les pays qui constitue quand
même le point névralgique de cette crise
à savoir le mali le niger et même le
burkina ont des difficultés politiques
aujourd'hui en 80 en 2012 si ces pays
n'avaient pas de dictateurs en afrique
de l'ouest aujourd'hui dans le ciel on a
pas de raison que les mâles et
l'habilité ils sont offerts donc ça
augure des jours prochains c'est délicat
au vu de tout ce que vous nous dites et
après l'annonce donc de l'armée dans
l'est de l'armée française au sujet de
la mort des djihadistes d'aqmi
quelle réaction à venir selon vous de la
part des organisations terroristes et
puis la fin de l'opération marque n est
ce qu'elle ne fait pas craindre une
résurgence du terrorisme
évidemment au sahel dans les pays que
vous venez de citer mais également en
europe puisque les frontières on le sait
sont heureuses alors d'abord je ne pense
pas que les terroristes du sahel ont une
capacité à mêler des actions en europe
par contre ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
les pays du sahel n'ont jamais été aussi
fragilisé aujourd'hui parce que tout
simplement le politique ne suit plus
quand je les dis aux nigériens à des
problèmes au mali parlons même pas le
burkinabé a des problèmes il ya juste à
peine une semaine
eu un attentat il ya une attaque dialyse
qui a tué plus de 140 à 160 civils et
cette attaque a eu lieu dans une zone
quand même qui a été définie comme ils
ont plu aux lutteurs de barkan donc
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire que la
présence de barkan empêche les massacres
de civils ou empêchent les terroristes
de continuer à faire des exactions dans
la région et ce départ la plus aussi
donné un mélange d'espoir si je peux le
dire ainsi
en tout cas l'annoncé de ce départ la à
certains un pays comme le mali par
exemple qui avait suggéré d'établir des
canaux de négociations avec certains
médias disent qu'ils sont locaux qui
sont maliens et on peut s'attendre
peut-être un cessez le feu avec
l'annoncé de ce départ de débarquant du
sel merci sega jerad avoir répondu à une
question je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue et fondateur du journal en
ligne
un magnet actu